Elon Musk melting liberal brains
everywhere for defending free speech and
taking a blow torch to the bidens the
Twitter CEO sitting down for a sprawling
interview and says he's not afraid to
speak his mind even if it hurts his
bottom line
do your tweets hurt the company we'll
see it in The Princess Bride
great movie great um
where he confronts the person who killed
his father
he says
I
offer me money
offer me power
I don't care I'll say what I want to say
and if if if
the consequence of that is losing money
so be it the journalist tried to lecture
the billionaire bad boy on conspiracy
theories but then musk shoved it right
back at his face
you do some tweets that seem to be or at
least give support to some who would
call others conspiracy theories some of
these conspiracy theories uh have turned
out to be true
which ones well like the the hunter
Biden laptop that's true Twitter and and
and others engaged in active suppression
of information that was relevant to the
public
um that's that's a that's a terrible
thing that happened that's election
interference as usual the media Hall
monitors are furious at a guy who speaks
his mind
first of all he's just like not he's
like the least entertaining poster ever
he's not funny or witty there's nothing
sort of clever interesting he doesn't
have any like innate talent for it and
yet desperately wants well that's the
case I don't think I dread going to a
site more than I dread going to Twitter
every bit because you see that the
dumbest stuff is underneath smart people
he turned Twitter into on many different
fronts a vehicle for authoritarianism it
was just bizarre he seems to talk a lot
now
um and spew on things that he doesn't we
shouldn't really be listening to him
about first of all I want to
congratulate Dr Perino you are now a
medical professional just like Dr Jill
Biden yes so if anything happens during
the show and you're feeling like a
little unwell just let me know and I'll
be right there yes I do have I'm a
little constipated
well that's a shame all right you know
what I love is just just watching that
tape for the first time how people are
emotionally uh connected to Twitter and
it's like a crime that it's not the way
they want it to be and it's kind of like
the way they always felt about Trump
it's like it's the tweets that murder us
most and actually there's a segment
coming up later in the show where it's a
similar thing it's like oh the good old
days when there was actually no
diversity of opinion those were really
great what's I what I really like about
Elon Musk is he is cancel proof so he is
the maybe the one person who maybe
there's more than one but he definitely
unlike Dave Chappelle right they come at
them but Elon Musk even more so they
come after him he's willing to do
interviews that's a that's a lot more
than somebody else that we could mention
who's supposed to be the leader of the
Free World who never talks to the Press
so I think that um the fact that he
can't be canceled means yeah I'll come
and answer your questions and they have
you better go to that interview prepared
right and that the question about the
hunter Biden laptop is also is a key one
because if you I don't know exactly what
made Elon Musk like the straw that broke
the camel's back that made him say you
know what I'm gonna take this thing over
but it might have been that issue yeah
and so he knows that issue very well so
you're going to bring it up you better
have your game face on um
Game Face indeed you know uh Katie uh
Dana doctor Perino brings up a point
about this like he he's uncancelable and
it's kind of a sobering but depressing
thought that the only way you might be
able to be truly free is to be so rich
it doesn't matter it's like it's only
billionaires that have well like they
call it Fu money but it's like we none
of us have that I'm glad that you said
that not me yes because I may have
actually accidentally said the real word
which you don't want to do on TV
um I think Elon Musk is entertaining
he's witty he's smarter than all the
people he sits down with for an
interview they don't come prepared and I
think you know all the people who sit
down with him claim that they're
Defenders of the first amendment that
they are for free speech and yet all
they do is question him about why he's
not censoring more right and they're
supposed to be the journalists right and
Elon Musk clearly thinks that people are
smart enough to take in information make
their own decisions about what they're
consuming and the media tends to decide
that they want to run the narrative not
actually defend the First Amendment and
for that reporter to be complaining that
his job is really difficult and terrible
because his you know duty every day is
to go on Twitter and peruse to find
things that he doesn't like like try
working construction try working a
kitchen job I mean do something a little
bit harder and maybe want some complain
so much about your feelings yeah like
being a co-host on a talk show it's
where I get my hands dirty uh Jessica
before I destroy you
um let's run this uh clip of uh of uh
Elon talking about Biden
you voted for I did actually do you
regret that
I mean
man
I I wish we could have just a normal
human being as president that's what I
want so you're not obviously you're not
happy with buying don't we all just want
to know all human beings
Jessica isn't that kind of what
everybody wants I mean isn't it strange
that it's millionaires who really are
just like us
totally relatable but every time they
wear it it looks better than when I wear
it
um it is I think the sentiment a lot of
people feel and that's people on both
sides of the aisle are just said we like
kind of someone in their 50s with some
good experience whether that's business
you're governor of a state and been
successful
Etc so I did think that that part of it
was relatable and that that pause
actually made you think for a second
like okay well what is it that I want
out of my political class but
I have to push back on the idea that he
came out of this looking great on the
Free Speech issue it wasn't touched upon
at least that I saw in it what happened
in Turkey the last few days before the
election that erdogan had requested that
all of these accounts get censored off
of Twitter and Twitter complied Twitter
actually was one of the best social
media companies for free speech in the
past in 2014 they actually took the
Turkish government to court in turkey
and they won that they should be able
did he have a defense for that no well
he didn't talk about it in this but no
and when you look at the accounts and
people have comb through it it looks
like it was people that erdogan didn't
want speaking out in an election that's
been closer than any other they're going
to a runoff erdogan has never had that
happen before he also um and I thought
David Faber did a good job pushing him
on this when he talks about the Allen
Texas shooter and continues to deny the
fact that the guy was a white
supremacist I don't know a lot of people
who get a swastika tattoo and don't
Harbor white supremacist feelings but
law enforcement has confirmed it and
then he goes after a bellingcat an
organization investigative journalist
that we've all spoken very positively
about on the show for things that
they've done from the Panama papers to
finding
um the 21 year old who leaked the latest
uh but is this all part of free speech
oh I'm not saying that he can't say it
I'm just saying that this doesn't make
him some Scion of the First Amendment it
makes him a high-class troll then that's
really what he is and on the Saurus
front and I don't want to get into can
you not criticize George Soros you can
make criticisms of him but when he gets
up there and he tweets that he's like
Magneto the Marvel villain who also was
a Jewish person who survived the
Holocaust and then he says that Soros
hates Humanity then the Jews starts
trending you know exactly what you're
doing if you're Elon Musk you're that
smart and you know that you're playing
in a very dangerous anti-semitic pool
with doing things like that and he
really shouldn't it's beneath him it's
Beneath The Genius of Elon Musk to be
that petty and that lame I think every
time that someone brings up how Soros
funded DA's have destroyed every it's
not always but I didn't and I left with
that he can I don't know enough about
Magento I'm not a nerd so I can't I
can't answer that I'll do some reading
what Jessica is saying is you can
compare a Jewish guy to another Jewish
guy right I mean you compare black guys
to black guys women to other women you
can't compare Sorrows to another Jewish
guy okay stop he's also a billionaire he
doesn't need you Jessica protecting him
also you're so upset a few people in
Turkey got censored how about Trump he's
our president he didn't say anything
when he got censored please wait is he a
nice censor excuse me CNBC looked like
they were interviewing a martian they
usually interview like CEOs investors
Tech analysts this guy is a software
developer and inner innovator usually
when you interview a businessman he
doesn't share his opinion he's not going
to say or do anything that's going to
affect the bottom line elon's brain is
not like that Elon is a create hater he
is trying to put people in outer space
he doesn't care about political
correctness this guy is about logic and
that's why in all of his companies he's
the creative force and then they have a
CEO that runs the business and that's
how it should be a woman a woman you go
girl you go she could even be Jewish
another woman Jewish don't criticize her
also CNBC is running so much
interference for Corporate America
cnbc's position now is let's not say
anything that could be a conspiracy
theory even if the conspiracy theory is
right because that conspiracy theory
could be bad for business it could be
bad for Pfizer it could be bad for any I
don't know Facebook you don't know any
of these other companies look what they
did during the pandemic Jessica all of
these corporations have had lots of ties
to China you couldn't say elably because
that was bad for business people got
censored not Turks Americans but on
Turkey he did have an expedition in part
and I'm not necessarily defending it but
also we're not the leaders of an
organization that is being asked to
throttle some back his explanation was
you could do you could do some of it so
that the majority of Twitter can stay
out there we don't know what that's like
and I think that it's easy for us to say
oh you should just leave it all open but
maybe that would mean that turkey
themselves would turn it all off which
would which is what the Iranians did and
not acceptable yeah it's not ideal it's
just that is his position that well
I understand that that's the statement
of the company but this is also the
company that used to fight back against
something like that and now they're not
really and there's been a hundred except
for they would censor Americans yeah
yeah you know again
look we got to move on Jessica I'm just
very happy for your sake that we have a
doctor here because you are in intensive
care you are in intensive care right now
we're gonna have to we're gonna need to
staunch is that the word staunch the
bleeding during the break
I think is that the word I don't know
well I get all my stuff from I don't
know everyone should be more comfortable
just saying I don't know I say it all
the time no you don't at home I wonder
Brian kill Mead I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now